Okay.
Wisecrack Michael here. It feels like every time a TV show ends.
There's one thing you can always count on. Disappointed fans,
things have gotten so bad that when game of Thrones ended angry,
fans flooded the internet,
creating a petition for the final season to be rewritten by competent writers.
This pattern constantly repeats a show is lauded as one of the greats of all
time until that pesky finale,
just look at what happened with last praised as the pinnacle of modern TV drama
until the very last episode, then the fandom went scorched earth,
admonishing,
the showrunners for lying and copying out with their twist ending even a series
as beloved, as breaking bad concluded to divisive reactions.
Some say the show should have ended two episodes earlier with the watermark
episode Ozymandias, the list of shows with disappointing endings.
It's seemingly limitless, but this got us thinking,
why is it so hard for TV shows to stick the landing?
Is there a foolproof way to do so that will please everyone,
or are TV finales inherently doomed to this fleece?
Let's find out in this wisecrack condition on how to ruin a TV finale.
Spoilers for a whole bunch of shows.
So what makes a great or terrible finale anyway,
it's not quite as simple as just comparing and contrasting the supposedly good
finales with the supposedly terrible ones. Every show is inherently different.
If Schitt's Creek ended with a dragon raining hell fire on its town,
I'll like game of Thrones.
That would be both nonsensical and also kind of awesome. However,
there is one constant that every show shares, no matter the genre,
us, the viewers,
the relationship between viewers and their TVs was once considered to be fairly
one-sided with viewers, mindlessly consuming, whatever was playing on screen,
but in the 1970s, sociologist, Elihu Katz redefined that relationship,
describing it as an active one,
whereby viewers choose what to watch in order to satisfy their own personal
needs. Based on this work,
psychologists began to study the bond that develops between a viewer and a TV
series and discovered it's not too different for real life relationships.
That makes sense just as we cry,
when something happens to a loved one in the meat world,
we cry when something terrible happens to a beloved fictional character on
screen,
this intense relationship between a viewer and a television show is called a
parasocial relationship. A phenomenon. We talk about a little in a recent video.
A parasocial relationship is a one-sided bond.
You might have with a celebrity or fictional character or sweaty YouTube post,
but finales are interesting, not because of our parasocial relationship,
but the way we could view them as a Tara social breakup,
when watching a TV series, we,
the viewers project ourselves into the lives of Ross, Rachel Dexter,
Tony and Walter White.
We get to know these characters deeply as if they were our own friends,
even though they will never know us or forget to Venmo is $7 for tacos,
Brandon, and after spending hours upon hours,
watching these characters and talking about them, it's only natural.
We become emotionally attached.
These fictional characters and series become a bedrock in our lives,
which only makes it harder when inevitably they end just like a real breakup.
The end of a TV series can evoke a flurry of emotion.
Of course not all breakups are the same.
Sometimes you calmly accept the lie that it wasn't your fault or come to
resent.
The idea that you're grateful dead fandom is a turnoff put the most emotionally
healthy breakups usually have something in common closure relationships.
This closure somewhat self-evidently comes from understanding the reason why the
relationship ended. Was it another person? Have we just grown apart?
Was it something I said, almost certainly in these moments,
we're just looking for an answer to latch onto to explain this sudden change in
our personal lives. But when deprived of a concrete answer, it can cause me,
I mean, anyone to start spinning out. Similarly,
audiences yearn for closure from television series,
we seek to understand why a series is ending just as we would try to understand
why a significant other is ghosting us.
Even after we go to medical school in hopes that we become their primary care
physician, just so we can know that they're alive. Samantha,
this is one of the reasons why shows that are abruptly canceled,
inspires such vitriol from audiences.
They feel like the closure that was owed to them has been taken away after the
TV series. Jericho was abruptly canceled on a cliffhanger.
Viewers sent thousands of peanuts and protests demanding to see the full story
played to its conclusion, which okay, weird, but good bit.
This need for closure extends the series.
Finales shows that end on an ambiguous note,
tend to find a much more divisive reaction. That series,
that wrap things up in a conclusive manner.
Look no further than the finale of the Sopranos.
One of the most hotly debated endings of all time as Tony sits with his family
and joined some greasy onion rings, he looks up and
fans weren't sure if this abrupt cut to black meant that Tony had been whacked,
or if their cable just gone out as such many were disappointed with the finale
due to this lack of closure at the time of the finales Erin angry fans,
yet again flooded the HBO website, demanding answers, no peanuts though.
Some reviewers even said the ending ruined the series as a whole,
while it divided audiences at the time,
it contemporary opinions about the episode seem to have become less vitriolic.
Similar tensions existed in the finales of breaking bad and mad men.
Both of which also ended on a somewhat ambiguous note for its protagonist.
Did Walter White succumb to his gunshot has Don really turned a corner and found
peace and enlightenment, or really fall back into the same huckster lifestyle.
Yet again,
both series deliberately leave these questions open-ended and deprive audiences
of the closure they so desperately want. And yet again,
a lot of people were in contrast,
if you look at the highest rated TV finales of all time,
one series consistently appears on every list, six feet under,
whereas the Sopranos and mad men divided viewers,
the six feet under finale was universally embraced with nary of peanut insight.
In fact, it's hard to find a single negative reaction to it,
even on the rapidly over opinionated internet, unlike the Sopranos,
the finale of six feet under provides total closure ending with a montage that
reveals the futures of all its main characters.
These final moments are structured so that you,
the viewer can cathartic fully say goodbye to each character.
We omnisciently see how each of their lives play out, who they'll marry.
The children they'll have. And yes, how they'll eventually die. One by one,
the familiar six feet under plaque comes up as they pass on allowing total
closure for the series and for the audience's relationship with these
characters, just as Claire drives off from her family,
moving away into the unknown,
we to bid farewell to the show and move on with our own lives.
Aside from closure. Another problem, plagues finales,
the twist ending.
This is kind of strange because in movies we love a good twist.
[Inaudible].
But to see why this doesn't work in TV,
let's return to the parasocial relationship with movies.
Audiences don't have the same time investment that they would with a television
series. A movie is only two or so hours of our lives.
Whereas we can build our one-way relationship with characters like Jim and Pam
over several years.
If we learn that the good guy we've known for 90 minutes is actually the bad
guy. It's no sweat,
but in TV it can feel like you've just been catfished by a Nigerian man calling
himself Williams.
I don't know about this.
After spending so much time with a series,
this kind of sudden twist is unsettling.
It should be no surprise then that the most poorly received finales all tend to
have an out of left field twist case.
In point Denaris target Aryan for seven seasons.
Denaris was the mother of dragons that heroic breaker of chains who the audience
cheered and rooted for yet in the final season of game of Thrones is turned into
a homicidal maniac out of the blue and started burning innocence of billions
alive. She suddenly,
without proper explanation became a completely different person than the
character we had invested in for seven plus years.
Understandably audiences rejected the twist.
This is also true for the finales of Dexter and lost on Dexter.
The titular character attempts to balance being a forensic investigator by day
and a successful serial killer by night, over the course of eight seasons,
Dexter crafts,
a meticulous domestic facade fooling his workmates and family into thinking.
He's just like them all the while indulging in his homicidal impulses.
I need you to put it on that time. I see it right away. I'm kinda in the middle.
But a funny thing happened over the course of the series.
The domestic facade that Dexter creates ultimately becomes his reality as he
gets married and has a son faced with the prospect of raising a child,
Dexter begins to try to quell his darker inclinations and becomes,
dare we say more empathetic.
But I was wrong. There is something I truly believe
everything's better after a bubble bath.
Well, he's still kills a whole bunch of people,
but at least he begins to question if this was really the right thing to do,
which only made it all the more random when the series ended,
not with Dexter on the run or behind bars or hanging up with scalpels,
but at some random lumberjack in the Midwest, and to add insult to injury,
he's abandoned his own son,
negating years worth of character growth in the process like Denaris Dexter
suddenly becomes a completely different person,
ironically for a show entirely about a man reconciling his identity.
We were left. Wondering if we ever knew him at all,
as for lost the finale twist. Wasn't so much of a trail of the characters,
but of the series as a whole,
for six seasons audiences debated and argued over loss, various mysteries,
who was the smoke monster. What's the deal with that for towed statue?
How can the Island heal a paraplegic? And most importantly,
what and where the hell is this Island?
Gosh.
One theory kept popping up over and over again in the early seasons that all the
castaways that actually died in the inciting plane crash and that the Island
itself was their purgatory.
This theory became so popular that show co-creator JJ Abrams had to come out and
denounce it early in the show's run. And in 2006 interview,
after the first season had aired Abrams explained that the purgatory theory is a
great one. I love that theory, but it isn't what it is.
I'd be frustrated if that were the answer I have to say,
but reception to the finale was marred and confusion was the Island purgatory,
basically purgatory parallel universe or D none of the above.
What the hell is happening.
The writers basically sidestepped the questions with Carlton Q saying that we
felt like lost was sort of the big bang theory.
And every question would only beget another question.
One common interpretation that the parallel universe is flashbacks simply took
place in the character's heads would mean that many events depicted in the final
season didn't matter or reveal which betrays a fundamental aspect of what makes
a good finale that everything we've previously watched needs to have mattered.
Ironically, Damon Lindelof might agree with the sentiment.
He Sates cheers as the perfect TV series finale,
because it's so definitively showed that everything we had watched mattered to
quote Lindelof. When Sam switches off the lights at the end of cheers,
you're basically like these going to be a bartender.
He's going to have more girlfriends. He's going to have further adventures,
but they're not as interesting as everything else that you just showed me.
You showed me the most important part.
I'm the luckiest son of a on her.
However, a series that undermine their own internal logic. Aren't,
well-received just as lost undercut its final season with a big twist.
Roseanne did the same revealing that the final season was a fantasy Roseanne's
head concocted to cope with her husband's.
I lost Dan last year when he had his heart attack.
Fans hated this finale so much that when Roseanne was revived in 2018,
the show just pretended it never happened. Similarly,
the finale of St elsewhere,
infamously ended with the reveal that the entire series took place in the
imagination of a boy with autism to say audiences were displeased would be an
understatement. In both cases,
the series went against the central tenant of good television that everything
we've watched matters. So how can you make audiences happy?
It's actually pretty simple by looking back to the good times,
the most revered finales don't focus on the end at all.
Instead they harken back to the beginning,
reminding the audience of the parasocial relationship they developed with the
series at the start.
This is why so many finales are filled with constant callbacks.
Look no further than the good place.
It's finale is stuffed with references to its early years from Chidi teaching
ethics lessons,
just like he had with Eleanor to the gang returning to their original,
good place neighborhood to Jason's obsession with the Jacksonville Jaguars.
Yeah.
Similarly,
the Veep finale was filled with Easter eggs even ends with a call back to its
very first episode. When Selena uses the R word on camera,
prompting her team to do disaster control Selena's press secretary suggest they
hold off on making a public apology and wait for a bigger story to get
everyone's attention. Let's not make it.
It's a story and panic. Okay. What if Tom Hanks dies?
And how does the final season of Veep end with Salinas funeral being
overshadowed by yes. The death of Meg Ryan's favorite loving.
Breaking news. I've just been told that four time Academy award winning actor,
Tom Hanks has died.
Or trying to get fans the same dopamine high they got when they first fell in
love with the characters just as we replay the good times of a relationship in
our head,
the best TV finales tap into the same emotional need breaking up naturally
feels pretty terrible.
So why even dwell in these negative feelings instead just focus on the
positive when things were great in the future seem limitless and Samantha was
still your day to the office, Halloween party, the Beavis to your Butthead,
and then you let them go and find the next show to binge watch at a disturbingly
frenzy pace. But what do you think wise crack? What makes a good finale?
And if you're interested in a deeper breakdown on the game of Thrones finale,
check out the deep or dumb video we put out a bit ago,
but you can't guess our conclusion while you're there.
Don't forget to leave a comment and let us know what you thought about the
finale.
We love to read your comments and to show you how much here are some of my
recent favorites.
Big thanks to our amazing patrons for your support set fire to that subscribe
button. Like it's the script for the lost finale and as always,
thanks for watching later.
[Inaudible].